Bush should be starting up very soon
there you go first smoke canister will
get used across coming in be planting in
the back to meet up you want us goes in
for the spray nmpk we'll go down let's
go gun being lost by young holding the
angle that's your gas canister shot in
the back as Yona again the second kill
one more up top he points the killing
call from up beyond us
there you go all our spot up at BC and
Claymore kill on baby and we've seen it
all and it's literally around at number
two than the grand final young in the
fuser spotted and will get taken down g
- what a futile flow rate tape well guys
in the last Rainbow six best of you
asked for it and we are here to deliver
what the best defender plays in our six
let nobody say we don't read that
comment section
[Music]
see now we've got some sick plays queued
up from the likes of echo smoke rook and
at least one from our Lord and Savior -
chocolate
so reinforce those walls drop that
barbed wire and for the love of God
pick up those armored plates because
we're coming at you with the best
defender plays from Rainbow six siege
and we have only one c4 on offense yeah
that is nice oh this is so smart he did
this before as well it didn't really
work out from Christie bus week 3 this
time it's just gonna remain standing
still and another spooky that you gonna
learn right on top of him as well gaming
will take the series it is gonna peek
out kill the thermite that's cookies
that was dusty the other one teammates
as well is very aware he is stuck to the
smoke he's gonna turn to Duke on over
here is gonna go for the shot he gets
another kill render the team urge that
gas grenade was a perfect coordination
both killed here by men dropping to yell
over the gun
he's gonna go for it again hey Ken can
he get the 8 he's gonna get the 8 here
and go to match boy bottom is
essentially going to be targeted you
know starting things off on to Yanis so
that iqs job is gonna be to find those
signal disruptors find the ADSL
fabien chumps on yuna waiting to see if
there's another there will be but fabien
diving around the corner pulls out the
pistol doesn't know what the IQ is
fabien double for the Swedish captain on
the map in the Astro potentially locked
armory wall is left soft so we could see
the quicker Russian runnin which so many
teams do quite a lot if they half the
ash so FDA pet gets the call that could
be something that he wants to go forward
almost seeing a little bit of a liquid
attack of an idea from surprise
[ __ ]
Oh quadruple c4 bomb a knife from sake
you've got to be kidding me
I call triple-a nice completely don't
stir truck skimming 35 seconds left in a
5 V 2 advantage you already a pressure
in from elation but they'll follow
mutilate a cars that guy you'll launch
the smoke canister in cars like he's
gonna finish off torque as well at range
now a to v3 for Shepherd cars that going
to work their way out of 20 seconds peak
has reacquired the diffuser and end are
battling up against the wall right now
hunter trying to use the skeleton key
but peak is going for a full rotation
and sloppiest pushed up the metal
detector Shepherd getting in the face
car so I can get a drop sloppy as well
down to the 2v2 can they complete the
comeback cars I could drop peak it's all
up to Hunter and he falls cars eka I
mean that was an ace liquid looking very
nice to try and take this right now
spawns is also gonna get very lit up
does the Ecuador this is gonna be doing
work his dangerous all the way with the
shotgun
what so aggressive from snake continues
to push restriction Heath goes another
one he's goes another one with the 3k
how does he do it
psycho he's got that top west side
control and he's gonna continue to try
and clear out these roamers but it's
just continuing to stall cancer a Kenny
the first kill of this series the second
kill of Victor the dark L of this series
takes out Giulio and pzd before he gets
a refractor of kamikaze what an amazing
roam from cancer of Kenny he's taken
almost all of wags help down as well
he's gonna get pushed by kamikazes he
gonna be able to get out that's the
fourth kill for tanto having the smoke
on the team Penghu means that with every
second that passes that he becomes
better and better I was on it I was
almost hoping Pengy would go up and
shoot the holes here we go speaking of
Penghu show are you doing almost getting
the kill there just a bit of damage just
nice job r1 and Gohan will go down
no more IQ turns the second
but are you ready for this oh you are
you kidding me with a flirt gonna take
it down and then drop below thank you
winds it up dude Newton Newton he wants
to drop in a straw I believe he shot one
bullet they're making his position hurt
in the copier of theirs we go to make
sure he knows well he still has one team
in Tahoe that is the talk might just go
for a quick charge back autumn very nice
very good communication and team play
now this is what lemon does not know
yogurts trying to set himself in hey
they all know it's the second one in
here he grabs one goes for the second
almost six and down Astro goes up to the
pistol as well what if you wanna go
thoughtful in the meantime getting one
on Gohan but a stranger goes in picked
it up oh you kidding me I chased him out
his second multi pistol kilduff in there
are you kidding me or should be starting
up very soon there you go first of all
canister will get used their crops
coming in be planting in the Paxton
meantime you want us goes in for the
spray nmpk will go down let's go got
being lost by young holding the angle
extra gas canister shot in the back as
the ona again the second kill one more
up top people who gets the kill and it
going happening call from up yonas
there you go all our spot up at BC and
play more kill on baby and we've seen it
all and it's literally around at number
two in the grand final young man
the fuser spotted and will get taken
down G - what a beautiful retake there
I'm thinking it's gonna be three Maps as
well I don't see this going any other
way but that three map prediction
definitely relies that's that's not
that's not real that's that's wow he
actually lost Tanaka
ladies and gentlemen it's happened we do
have a - Shaka being played for the
first round of this consulate map it is
gonna be old King George on the
rat-a-tat-tat sir
avian with a great bandit trick on the
main garage gonna get one of the
thermite charges and that means this
attack is going to stall out at least
somewhat Oh a nice kill from the Bandit
of avian as we were just speaking about
of on to King Leo it's gonna leave
Redeemer and Chavez now Charlotte goes
down to the SMG of eclipse total roll
switches here now as you see is as you
can see eclipse now playing smoke as
well so they not only are they changing
operators but they're all changing the
actual hot like roles they play - you
see eclipse is gonna play on-site
instead of roaming and as Eclipse I
think might actually have the most
amount of frags in North America right
now oh he's been having a been a banner
year I mean even even in that infamy
loss he dropped he drew I think dropped
the most frags of anyone here you can
see it even gonna drop down nobility
from him in order to get out in time but
behind the Montaigne there's a plane
going down neck rocks tries to come out
but a good read Canadian the jungle will
stop the plant in its tracks
Shantay eliminating that crux as he
tried to push out and your diffuser is
once again down then became looking the
wrong way not expecting shot take to be
there to - to Canadia takes out shot a
it's the class of yonas who's only on
one shot goes proud
I'm gonna be playing that black bear to
get training some Pete's and Canadian
back on the sledge again as well so
similar line I'm mostly coming out from
fnatic although they will be playing a
little bit different especially with
that of course that cap can the shots
almost connected to mesas he is back on
that foot 12 again there we go with the
double kill and fnatic or closer and
closer he's still on the outside the
Apple 12 we've seen living through this
on millennium what do you miss you have
to North America right now
so literally shredding them neo and one
more take it away ceases we'll drop it
but not enough to finish off the ash
lanes careful boys
last man alive is necrosis MV K's on the
floor oh my god Berto go get this second
in the round going for third narrowly
missing the shots through the wall onto
Jarvis who reassesses and a nice angle
here could potentially net him a kill
and yes it will still see Jarvis hauled
up upstairs on the Dokdo try to rotate
away but remember they have that
beautiful camera that in the hallway and
it just gives them info on hyper they
take him out and Jarvis with one more
Jarvis going ham here this Nix is trying
to hold it in they just drop the black
made on the floor what is happening
Jarvis destroying Mouse sports
Jarvis you ever hear the tale of Jonah
well those were sick plays indeed but
unfortunately not every single one
resulted in a win now the plays in our
next section hit the W every single time
in one VX situations here are the best
defender clutches from our six he takes
down Billy monster code the defuser a
little bit and just go for the blood and
you said he was over but cybers managed
to recover this reach T sub tsk he's all
Doutzen s keep rotates around oh wait
you see Gail was an obese give the
deagle how he does it he gets to your
head shots in a row next you're insane
yeah well I trust y'all gonna go out as
easily try sponge it down you take down
home folks that just all the way to the
site order laying down just lay down and
Nick all the flights finally finds a
fill of his own booze down and it'll be
a 3v2 ten seconds left to marry you and
walk up and engaging with the Montaigne
Matt will be there picking up yet
another
Wacka will need to come back to site all
he needs to do is stop that defuse he'll
be greeted by a Montaigne trying to rush
past abuser Blanca will do I cannot
cover
what did it say playful walk up oh she
says she just made a sound by walking
through the metal detector oh what a
shot
GC are things down drugs very nicely
levy takes down revolts however three
people situation all down sucia
now it's UV white Peaks around oh my god
II pushed this house so easily it's all
down / in a 1v1 situation fall down to
GC are trying close just I would get
that fuse it down what a nice few shots
there as padding your stats takes down
out easy and trying to find out where
exactly his eyelash is he's gonna be
trying to pay your mouth being gonna
know that slash is only one of these
birds fly angles and he knows it against
the book here he knows that it takes
down slash waiting for his opportunity
that yokai is doing so much work
excellent job to Leon and making it
happen it's not even gonna be funny wow
what a play from him you could see that
liven is doing his best to try and
dispatch it but it's just not gonna
happen
as the time didn't windows down to the
last 10 seconds takes it's gonna force
his way into the site and take out a
lambs lack he's still in a perfect
denial position he'll whip out the
shotgun to make it happen and it looks
like he's gonna not make these
successful aces will finish him off the
yokai drone though from Leon will deny
the plant in the final second oh so much
damage done from that one yokai and they
knew was there for almost the entire
round
rogue is just gonna peak everything /
tosses out one toxic babe but he's a man
on an island he'll get it down onto mark
and there's still smoke there to
possibly stop a push but he's gonna get
doubled up on / takes outfox a pulls out
the shotgun they're gonna need to go for
a plant Mark's coming out he just needs
to solid hide but the time is in there
/ you do I to live cloud 9 what are you
doing what also keep your eye on BC the
mirror is still playing he does see the
Valkyrie and I don't know if Canadian
has determined that he's been drone out
I'll go for a couple pre fires and he
managed to hit it oh no
Canadian why are you there bobbing with
a very easy kill and it's gonna be up to
BC to clutch yet again the mirror
playing inside of small office he'll go
for a c4 tosses it out
go ahead BC that's that's the lift for
two seconds can paint you fight him no
evil geniuses will stick the third round
BC another torch 30 seconds on the clock
Bryan is gonna start fishing and he did
pick up that the fuser and gets to kill
onto lucky as shorts do come wakes from
that LMGs there's those shot fine easily
Bryan gets himself another kill as the
lambs will fall sees the smoke and
thought time stays to a 1vs1 Bryan
versus meat be hose this happened at 4
v2 has end up into a 1vs1 but from below
me P still has a c4 and brand is
actually thought the putt he could have
got that plant toy so this is where the
Intel's gonna be fed and he is gonna get
tagged and meet me essentially should be
able to win the shrine fight he's
actually gonna dig up first name
potentially transfer to c4 as I will get
tossed wait does he - what it does maybe
gets the coach what why from maybe we
talk about his game sense bread now
waiting in the hallway
it's gonna have to buy at his time he's
got a whole minute to work with here
Nora on the other hand are going to have
to start droning out and looking for
their opponents they don't want to jump
the gun they don't want to lose because
they stack up and get caught in the same
spray or anything silly like that so
they're gonna calculate this move and
push unlikely all together
EMP is coming out to clear any potential
traps a nice angle being played from red
he's gonna miss the shots though it was
for another one onto the windows for
balcony it's been second follow-up shot
on - JJ getting the stature but the
defuse is being planted right now near
islands and they're all brunette what is
happening
fine Tony take it well guys that's all
we got for you on best of this week now
there is one more thing I have to
mention the guy behind me Dimitri the
one who's always watching anime in every
video well last week I asked you to pick
the next anime he would watch you did so
in the comments section and it turned
out to be my hero academia so that's
what he's rocking right now
now if you want more r6 content don't
forget to mount that LMG spray down the
sub button hit the like button get in
that comment section and I will see you
next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]